we are going to be starting in just
one more minute
okay we are ready to begin today's
session
and thank you again for joining today
welcome to the first session on
bioinformatics for
infectious diseases in today's session
we will speak about the emergence and
development
of bioinformatics and infectious disease
research
we will discuss what infectious diseases
are and how they can be characterized
from a data perspective
specifically next generation sequencing
data
we will also show several examples for
bioinformatics
analysis methods that are used in
pathogen diagnostics
viral evolutionary studies antiviral
drug discovery
vaccine design as well as the
characterization for
emerging drug resistance to do so
we will rely on the tbinfo analytical
platform
designed for virology studies for those
of you who have still not completed
their registrations you will also get a
good overview of the amix logic
infectious diseases bioinformatics
training program
interested in effective utilization of
bioinformatics for
infectious diseases immunology and
microbiology
for all of you joining us for the first
time my name is
beepsha biswas and i am the omixlogic
community manager
responsible for daily interactions with
thousands of users
that are part of our bioinformatics
community
managed by pine biotic over the past
couple of years we have seen
participants from all over the world
join our training programs take
online coursework and utilize our big
data
analysis tools in various research
projects
let me start by introducing our company
and collaborators
to share with you details about the
upcoming omics logic bioinformatics
for infectious diseases program and
explain
how the training resources we will
discuss today
can be used effectively for research
independent learning
or as a structured training program
what we will discuss today and
throughout this program
is a result of hard work by an amazing
team led by company co-founders
dr alfred tober and dr leonid brotsky
dr tober comes from a medical background
and has extensive expertise
in oncology immunology and biochemistry
of inflammation and has been recognized
internationally for its generous support
of many research projects and
initiatives
that support data science training and
applications in medicine dr leonid
brodsky
is the director of the turbo
bioinformatics research center
at university of haifa and is an expert
in bioinformatics and biostatistics
he has numerous publications in
mathematics and bioinformatics
and over the course of his career has
developed multiple novel algorithmic
approaches to biomedical data analysis
under his leadership the tauber research
center started collaborations with
research
teams in such universities as the
university of california san francisco
institute pasture
julian university and many others where
research labs are working
on cutting age research projects
studying viral
and bacterial infections and designing
novel drugs and vaccines to treat and
prevent
infectious diseases now
before we move on i wanted to invite
everyone to come and join
two of our groups that we have on
linkedin and on facebook so dr mohit if
you can please uh
share the links in the chats so if you
are new to our community we would
urge you to come and join these groups
where we keep sharing updates
regarding these programs as well as any
other updates
from the industry so please join us here
in the first session of bioinformatics
for infectious diseases
we will talk about next generation
sequencing
to introduce the program to you
we have our program mentors and let me
start by
introducing them to you dr harpreet kaur
is a certified omix logic trainer and
expert by information
who will guide the sessions and assist
participants with projects and
analysis during the program her area of
specialization is in genomics and
machine learning
dr mohit mazumdar is a romix logic
project
mentor and an expert in big data
computational analysis
dr mazumdar has a phd in computational
biology
and over 10 years of experience working
with
industry and academia elia brodsky
is our co-founder and ceo at buying
biotech in his current role he has
extensive experience working together
with
industry and academic partners that are
applying multiomics integration
and bioinformatics to a variety of
biotechnology
and clinical applications
i will pass it on to elia to talk about
the increasing role of bioinformatics
and data science in
infectious disease research and
introduce you to the types of challenges
data analysis data organization
integration and visualization can solve
for biomedical research projects
over to you elia
thank you
so let me start this by asking you
a few questions before we begin so the
first question
i have is what is your current level of
education i know that we have here
participants from all over the world
and what we are interested in is not
just conducting these online programs
but also developing a long-term
relationship with a community that is
interested in application of
bioinformatics in a variety of
domains so let me ask you this question
if you could please
put your response in the chat box so
number one what is your current level of
education
1a high school 1b undergraduate degree
1c graduate degree 1d postgraduate
degree
all right great excellent thank you very
much
what we will do with this information is
we will collect it and analyze it for
our future programs
we understand that those that come from
high school or undergraduate degrees
need a lot more preliminary training and
so we will help
guide you to that training so that you
are familiar with the terminology
and are able to do the analysis
uh effectively for those of you that are
graduates and have postgraduate degrees
we welcome you to
benefit from the more advanced materials
and so we'll help shape that
curriculum for you introducing some of
the more advanced topics and projects
for you
let me ask you another question what do
you expect from this program so this is
the first session in our bioinformatics
for infectious diseases
and today we'll talk about next
generation sequencing
what kinds of questions and what kinds
of projects you can do with different
types
of topics that we will cover
so what do you expect from this program
by joining this program you can learn
about bioinformatics in general sense
you can get familiarized with infectious
diseases and some of the challenges that
are being
researched there you can get an overview
of bioinformatics and virology so a lot
of people join this program to
learn about covet 19 and other viral
sequences
and then 2d apply bioinformatics to a
research project so if you already have
a research project
in mind the data set what would that be
okay excellent so it's great to know
that a lot of you
are interested in a combination of these
and that's fine so really what we're
interested to understand is how
well can you uh can you
utilize some of the resources that we'll
cover today
to specific projects that you have
a true passion and a drive and a
motivation to
address so excellent thank you very much
for answering these questions again we
will
analyze this information for all of the
participants of this program
and we'll be interacting with you some
of you have seen and you will see at the
end of this session that we have
multiple options to register for the
program some of it includes interaction
with
a mentor and so this information is
critical for a mentor to be effective
in those types of interactions
so let's talk briefly about what
infectious diseases are and how are they
different from non-infectious diseases
an infection is essentially an invasion
of an organism's body
tissues by disease-causing agents or
pathogens
their multiplication and the reaction of
host tissues to the infectious agents
and the toxins that they produce
so the infectious diseases are also
called transmissible diseases or
communicable
diseases and they are the result of an
infection the pathogens include
viruses bacteria fungi parasites
all of them have subcategories but all
of them have
the key pathogen that is causing that
infection that's why they are
transmissible and communicable because
the pathogen could be spread between
individuals
non-infectious diseases are chronic
diseases so they cannot be
passed on unless they have a genetic
background
and they're caused by such factors as
environment nutrition
lifestyle and genetic inheritance the
world health organization recognizes
four main types of chronic and
non-infectious diseases cancer
cardiovascular chronic respiratory
diseases like asthma
or chronic obstructive pulmonary disease
and diabetes
but we will also talk in the context of
this program about many pathogens that
actually contribute
to some of these non-infectious diseases
so we will see that there's actually
a good relationship between both of
these and it's not such a clear cut
now when we talk about these pathogens
one of the key ways that they
harm the host is by replication so the
replication of pathogens in the host
leads to a major interference that
starts from
membrane disruption as in the case of
viruses
and release of toxins as in the case of
many bacterial pathogens
also bacteria and
they colonize different tissues
interfering with
the function and so many of these
interferences
include modification of molecular
biological pathways
that are designed to fend off intruders
and signal
to neighboring cells and organs of
coming
danger and so you can see that
here you can see this is actually covet
19
replicating and infecting the host cells
you can see how much of that virus
is coming out which means that inside
these cells there's an
active production of these virions and
here you can see how
some of the viruses and pathogens are
also introducing specific signaling
of toxins that actually cause
different types of cell death and
apoptosis
including oxidative stress and other
types of stresses
bacteria often times damage
the membrane and also
cause secondary passenger
pathways to be modified and modulated
and so you can see
that a lot of this leads to scarring and
tissue
damage for example some of the pathways
are not even
kind of what the virus or the pathogen
causes
they are the response but because the
response is so strong
it can have a major impact a long-term
impact on the organs
so in the context of this program we'll
take a look at some of these
processes identify such molecular
pathways and try to understand
the relationship between the host and
the pathogen
now how can the host protect itself
the host can fight infection using their
immune system so here you can see
a few gifts that you can easily find
on the internet and these gifts really
show
you how uh the immune system responds so
here for example you can see a white
blood cell chasing
a pathogen uh here you can see
what those uh blood cells look like as
they seek to identify
different types of present antigens that
they would be uh signaling that
this death is under this cell is
undergoing infection
and so some of this is related to the
immune system
here you can also see an example of
bacterial growth
and the result of penicillin now
penicillin
kills bacteria this is actually produced
by hhmi this
little gif and you can see that what it
essentially does is it just
breaks the membrane of the bacteria so
we will talk about some of these
processes and some of the interactions
we know that the host microbiome has
some
antibacterial producing bacteria
and viruses we know that
there it's a complex system and so the
major
way that the host can fight off
intruders is the immune system so we'll
learn about that
and the major way that we can help
get that immune system activated are
vaccines
but we'll also talk about antibacterial
and antiviral drugs
and how do they interact with the
different pathogens and how do the
pathogens respond
to some of these viral antiviral and
antibacterial treatments
developing resistance so we'll talk
about some of that and importantly how
to identify
such trends in data now vaccines have
been discovered a long time ago as far
back as the earth
early 1800s and today
of course we hear a lot about the
copit19 vaccine
but really we're talking about a
renaissance in vaccine design and
development
a completely new approach that is driven
by molecular knowledge
now overall vaccines and antiviral drugs
like antibiotics or
antiviral drugs and antibiotics have
been
very very effective health measures but
they come together with
other epidemiological control measures
or health measures
that were very effective in reducing the
number of
death incidents from these pathogens
these types of pathogens so for example
you can see here
a brief chart this is the rate of death
per 100
000 population per year and you can see
how
that rate of death has been spiking
around pandemics but overall
what we have seen over the course of the
20th century from 1900s to 2000
we have seen a major maybe 10
or more fold reduction in death rates
as a result of control measures and
ways to disinfect
so reduce the number of pathogens in
water in the environment that we live in
and you can see here for example the
first use of penicillin
the vaccines introduced and then
the number of people getting vaccinated
so all of these measures have been
very effective however what we know
today
is that in the 21st century this
trajectory essentially changed we've
seen a number
of pandemics or epidemics that have
caused us to lose confidence in the
measures that have been so effective
right so we've seen
the flu coming from swines the flu
coming from
avian flu right so h1n1
all of these deadly viruses like ebola
and
of course now we have covet 19. you can
see how
this vex this rate of death from covet
19 has been surpassing
some of the other major causes of death
that are not
necessarily a result of pathogen so it's
very
important to understand that this
trajectory is now
putting us into a new age for vaccine
design
antiviral drug design and antibiotic
approaches to treatment that combine
molecular data
and analysis tools that allow us to have
a rational approach
to answering such challenges and so
what we'll talk about in the program and
in today's session the focus of today's
session is going to be
on next generation sequencing because
this major type of data
has completely revolutionized the way
that we
understand pathogen so up until
this type of technology was introduced
our understanding of pathogens was
mostly driven by our ability to observe
in using a microscope how these
pathogens reproduce
and a lot of that has to do with
isolating pathogens and studying them
in the lab now we know that many
of bacteria and viruses are very
difficult to handle
and study in the lab and isolate and
also to look in the microscope obviously
viruses are very difficult to look at in
the microscope
so the sequencing technology has really
changed the way that we understand the
genetic material
that can characterize the communities
that they live in
and the way that they interact with the
host so here you can see
a brief overview of what types of
insights we can get
from this type of sequencing data so we
can
understand the population structure and
evolutionary history
we can look at specific sequences for
detecting and characterizing strains of
these outbreaks and we've seen
in the previous pandemics of ebola and
the coronavirus that we are in
right now how this type of data has been
coming out
almost in real time allowing the
international community of scientists to
start
asking very specific questions about
where is this virus coming from
how is it changing over time what can we
do
to try to apply previous strategies that
were successful
to this current challenge of course we
are talking here also
about other types of more in-depth
questions that are not diagnostic but
they're really to understand the
mechanisms
that these pathogens utilize to infect
and overcome host responses
and this is important because this basic
biology
this basic science has really driven a
number of translational projects that
help us
make these vaccines and antiviral drugs
and antibiotics
much much more effective because we
understand the logic and can design
within parameters
that save time and save effort that is
troubleshooting and kind of trial and
error based
so as a result of this kind of data this
kind of genomic data
we now understand and can study
effectively
the interaction between the type of
virus
and the type of host response in stages
we can look at time course of disease
progression by looking at
viral modification and host response and
measuring that host response in very
specific
types of data we can also look
at different types of variation at the
genomic level to understand
resistance to antiviral drugs and
evasion from such treatment over time
that's also an important part of it
we can also really characterize how the
process of disease
happens giving us insight into protein
protein
interactions and routes for intervention
and here you can see also a
characterization of the immune response
over time
and really this ability to characterize
the response over time
is of course very useful for precision
medicine so actually
infectious diseases is one of those
areas of precision medicine that has
been
tremendously improving as a result of
genomic
data and genomic medicine in general has
been most effective in addressing
such pathogens as we are discussing in
this program
now it's not just the sequencing data
right together with the sequencing data
there are some other types of data that
are important to incorporate
to be able to ask such questions and
answer them definitively
and so we'll look in the context of this
program
at omics data different types of omics
data or multi-omics data
that includes dna variation host gene
expression measurement of protein
abundance
composition properties of microbial
communities and all these are very
different types of data that we all need
to know
how to effectively study and mine for
patterns to understand such host
pathogen
interaction so let's look at a couple
examples
of how we can deal with data and what
kinds of data sets we will be dealing
with
to be able to ask such questions so the
role of bioinformatics which the
name of this program obviously is
bioinformatics for infectious diseases
so the role of bioinformatics and being
able to study
viral and bacterial pathogens
is to kind of put the infectious disease
specific infectious disease into the
context of data
and so as researchers are able to access
process analyze and visualize these
kinds of high throughput data
they are able to start asking questions
and answer them definitively make making
assumptions and testing those
assumptions by
evidence provided in the data so you can
look at viral
genomics and evolution immune response
and identify biomarkers that help detect
those
and then also microbiome and infection a
relationship that is very fascinating
because our whole view
of the way that these pathogens kind of
exist
and live together in communities is
changing because of this ability to
sequence data and understand
what is really going on in real life so
we'll talk about this in a section in in
a second
but first let's talk about this one
major way that bioinformatics is
changing our understanding of the
microbial world so
the original uh appreciation of microbes
as i mentioned was a result of seeing
these
pathogens in a microscope
and eventually today we have so much
data about these pathogens that we're
starting to ask completely
different questions about the
communities that they live in
and so today we have a realization that
these are communities or whole organs
that actually
have not only a specific pathogen but
a whole community of pathogens that
coexist and form
the specific relationship with the host
because of their composition
and so we can talk about things like the
microbiome
and specifically the virum as well
which is where we can understand
all of the viruses present in a
particular
environment so uh we
know that the virum the studies of the
viral
are in their infancy because it has only
recently become possible to see the
viral
in large sequence data using
bioinformatics tools that can detect
relationships between viruses
despite its extreme nucleotide sequence
diversity so
we're not talking about a single
pathogen we're talking about
many variations of the same pathogen
that is very dynamic right
they are changing all the time now
the size of the mammalian birum is not
even known
although our own cells are outnumbered
about 10 fold by our bacterial
microbiome the number of viruses may be
even 10 fold higher and human feces
alone
contain about 10 to the eighth to 10 to
the ninth viruses per gram so billions
and billions
of viruses and additionally the
mammalian birom is continuously updated
through rapid evolution of viruses
and through exposure to viruses in the
environment or in other mammals
so as a result because of the
differences in the viral and the
microbiome in different communities
we see that interaction between
different hosts for example
animals and humans can be particularly
dangerous and so one of the questions
that we can ask
is how do these pathogens change when
they go between different environments
one of the key issues here though is
that viruses
are not even alive in a traditional
sense
so the sequencing data an additional
aspect of the sequencing data
is really leading us to ask very basic
questions about pathogens
so we know that the way we categorize
life is actually divided up into three
large
domains bacteria archaea and eukarya
and under this classification system
viruses are not even a part of
the tree of life so they're certainly
not alive
in the classical sense because they're
not capable of
metabolizing or replicating on their own
but at the same time we cannot just
classify them as
inanimate because they are built of
biological molecules and contain
genetic information and so we see
that they are in between kind of being
alive and dead and that
problem is changing the way that we
think of life in general so
it's really the study of infectious
diseases using
data is changing our understanding of
life
so there is a debate about how to
classify viruses
and specifically this debate recently
has been kind of heating up because of
discovery of these extremely large
viruses such as pandora virus
they're so gigantic that they can be
seen with a light microscope and contain
more genetic information than some
bacteria and so it has been proposed due
to some
intriguing similarities in dna sequences
specifically in the gene that encodes
for an enzyme
called rna polymerase that such large
viruses
actually constitute a fourth domain of
life and so
here we can see some
joke or a funny version of the tree of
life where we have bacteria
eukarya archaea and then a fourth domain
maybe it even includes aliens so really
the ability to sequence such information
and understand what is going on in the
real environment where these pathogens
exist
is not only changing the translational
aspects of
antiviral vaccine design and
antibacterial
antibiotics and things like that it's
also changing our very basic
understanding of life
and the way that we can approach is
asking some of these
very fundamental questions so at this
point i'm going to pause
i'm going to make sure that we don't
have any questions so are there any
questions about what we've done so far
i wanted to make sure that those of you
that have joined the session for the
first time that you have already joined
our communities like linkedin and
facebook groups that beeps have
mentioned and for those of you that are
already a part of this program that you
are starting to think about
some of the ways that you can use
sequencing data to answer
questions that either are basic or
translational
about the nature and the function of
these pathogens
and their interaction with the host so
are there any questions that i can
answer right now
okay so please keep in mind if
i am going through the slides and you
have any questions that come up
you can write down that question in the
chat box and we will
make pauses for such questions and
answers and you're free to
ask those questions either during that
time or before that time
so when we have a pause we can address
any of the questions that come up
so let's talk about next generation
sequencing what is next generation
sequencing
what kind of data does it produce what
can we do with that data
so the process of next generation
sequencing is when we take
a sample a biological material for
example spit
saliva and we can then sequence the dna
or the rna that is inside this
biological sample
the problem is that in between getting
the sequencing data and being able to
ask the questions we need to structure
the data and so we'll talk a little bit
about the process
of bioinformatics pipelines that allow
us to structure the data
and start making that data available to
ask specific questions
now the amount of such data is
increasing
exponentially here you can see some
information
on viral sequences and this information
is located in a couple
of locations for example we have the
joint
genome institute that hosts uh
in by january 2018
we see here over 700 000
total viral sequences or over close to
400 000
unique viral sequences so a huge amount
of data
over 13 000 complete annotated genomes
of different viruses and millions of
sequences
of viral genes and proteins so a huge
repository of data and the
important part of this is that this kind
of sequencing data
is available in both raw and processed
format so when we talk about sequencing
we'll talk about how sequencing is done
different formats of sequencing data
and remember all of this data is
accessible so all of these repositories
are available for
anybody to have access to and in the
context of the program
we'll have sessions where we actually
access this data
and we start asking questions of this
data using some of the analytical tools
that we will discuss here in a second
so there are several approaches to
metagenomic and viral sequences
sequencing uh targeted amplicon
and whole dna and rna and these types of
data produce
very different types of results that
we'll talk about in a second
so targeted amplicon sequencing you can
see that
they're here together is really asking
is really amplifying signal or
information
that is contained in specific regions
those regions could be designed for
a particular type of a pathogen or
they could be specific to a gene that
can help us
understand taxonomic relationship
when we talk about whole dna and rna
sequencing this is a completely
different approach that produces
different types of data that allow us to
try to reassemble what is
in the data either by mapping on a
particular set of references
and looking at abundances or trying to
understand
what novel information might be there
that we are not
capturing from a reference database but
still could be assembled based on
an assembly of longer and longer pieces
of genetic information
because of the way that we observe that
those pieces connected together in a
number of different reads so we'll talk
about that in just a second
but these types of methods are used for
different types of purposes
for example you can see here an
application of
genomic sequencing to track viral
outbreaks for example if we already have
identified
what is this outbreak caused by what
type of a pathogen
we can amplify specific viral sequences
and then look for specific types of
changes in the viral genome let's take
one group of viruses a family of viruses
like coronaviruses
and we can start asking the questions
well how is
the data that we have in this type of
sequencing different from
a reference genome of that particular
family or
a member a species of those viral
families
now we can also look at all of the data
that is available
so sequence all dna or rna align the
reads to
a virus reference on multiple references
for example a whole database of
references
and we can now look at what's called
metagenomic next generation sequencing
which allows us to study all of the
genetic information
in those in that sample here you can see
some of the applications so applications
are detection of a specific
microorganism
detection of specific mutations or
changes in gene expression because of
antibiotic resistance being developed in
a group of viruses again if you think of
that community of viruses or bacteria
they are not a single identical member
replicated many times this is a
community that has some diversity
oftentimes one of those members
could become resistant and eventually
replicate
to cause resistance to be su
sufficient for this the cells to not be
able or the body not to be able to deal
with them
we can also look at changes in the
microbiome
and those changes themselves could be a
result of a condition
or could drive the condition they could
increase
risk of susceptibility they could also
change the way that our body metabolizes
and deals with different types of
challenges
in the environment and we can also study
host response so we can look at
changes in transcriptomic or rna
sequencing
to identify genes and pathways expressed
as a result of infection
and in the course of infection as well
now this type of data is produced by
sequencing machines these sequencing
machines
include short read sequencers and we
will primarily in this program deal with
short
sequence data so this includes short
reads
that are generated from the full genome
or
whatever sample we have and we also have
what's called
long read sequencers so these for
example pack
bio can be as long as tens of thousands
of nucleotides
when we talk about short read sequencing
they could be as short as
30 nucleotides long so very very
different types of data
and the challenges and the type of data
that they produce
are also very different so let's talk
about that
a little bit when we have data coming
out of the sequencer
it comes in multiple types of formats
and we'll refer to these formats in
all throughout the program so three
formats that you have to remember at
this point
fast queue which is information about
sequencing reads
and those sequencing reads will include
the actual sequence as you can see right
here
the length and also quality so
quality for each one of the characters
how
confident are we in the quality of that
particular nucleon time
fasta files are files that contain
references or full assembly so when we
talk about
a full genome we're typically going to
find that genome
as a sequence in a faster file and then
also importantly for the references we
will have
what's called the genome transfer format
so gtf
file or gff file these files contain
information about genomic elements so
where do they start
where they end and what do we know about
them so this is
annotation for the fasta file formats
what do they look like here's an example
of a fasta file
you can see that the faster file
typically contains the name
of whatever that file is about so this
is a
spotuptera frugi peridot isolate sf9
scaffold 12 so scaffold is like a
piece of the full genome whole genome
shotgun sequencing
here you can see another example rabies
virus the complete genome
if we look at the fasta file from a
human genome we will see there
that file divided into chromosomes so
divide it up into pieces
sometimes we can get a fasta file with
multiple
genomic sequences and they will have
these kind of separators
between the actual sequences so this is
a fastq
file the fastq file contains information
about reads
so here we can see the read please tell
me
what is the length of reads that you
observe
in this fastq file
hint this number is in the file that you
see on the screen
so what is the number okay
excellent right so we're starting to
learn how to read these files
you're exactly right so here you can see
the read
itself and here you see length 160. so
just making sure that you guys are
paying attention
so when the process of sequencing
happens we take
genomic dna that dna is broken up into
short pieces and that could be
anywhere between 30 and 300 base pairs
this is an example for a specific type
of sequencing
but here then we have library adapters
that are placed in a flow cell these
flow cells
based on the machine can be of very
different sizes and so they contain
a lot of variation in the number of
reads that we can
sequence and then we have a this complex
chemical process of pcr bridge
amplification to produce enough material
for the
machine to be able to read it and the
way it reads the machine
reads the sequence is by looking at
image analysis so we have different
colors for different nucleotides as they
attach
they are we can observe them and then we
have these images and that's where this
quality score is coming from the quality
score is from the analysis of these
images
to give us an insight into how clear was
that
signal so as a result we have this
long sequence as the process of
sequencing happens
we have these long sequences coming out
and the sequences
are in short pieces so when we get fast
q reads
or fast q files out of a sequencer like
this
shotgun sequencing one of the major
challenges is to then
annotate to understand where did that
particular read come from
if we have a long sequence the sequence
is already assembled for example we're
looking at a particular pathogen and
using senior sequencing
the challenge is then to align to other
sequences and try to find variation
so here are the two main approaches to
analysis
for these types of data sets one
example for fast q files is
analysis based on mapping and fasta
files
is analysis based on alignment
multiple sequence alignment in this
example to understand
relationships here it's to detect
variants
so two different approaches and we'll
talk about them
in greater detail now when we have this
genetic sequence what is
the genetic or genomic sequence
uh what are the letters in there the
letters are called
nucleotides right what are some of the
letters that you know that are
in nucleotide sequences
all right excellent a t c
and g so we have four nucleotides these
four
nucleotides form what's called amino
acid sequences so really when we look at
this kind of a sequence
we can convert all right look
at nasios also knows the full name so
exon so we have here a lot of
people that have this down so you can
see here
that we have the nucleotide sequence and
then we have these
reading frames and there are several
options for these reading frames
so we can get different types of amino
acids
based on the changes that we observe so
a typical process
is to map these nucleotide sequences
into codons so who knows what are codons
i'm sure that atanasius knows but maybe
um other people know as well
who knows what are codons
all right so combination of three bases
that code an amino acid bodies thank you
and as an osteos
yep okay so these are triplets of
nucleotides
each combination represents an amino
acid
so when we look at the changes
in those nucleotides we're expecting
different types of changes
in the amino acids and so what you can
see here
is an example of an analysis where you
have the nucleotide sequence
mapped into codon so you will have a
three
letter for each one of your letters here
so that means that these three make this
one amino acid and this codon mapping
follows specific rules so we know what
the different types of
amino acids are coded by what types of
codons
and there could be a lot of variation
right so there could be a lot of
different changes
there now importantly when we think of
functional implication of a nucleotide
change
we are thinking about a nucleotide
change that produces a change
in the amino acid and so there are
multiple different things that we can
expect from those changes
including a stop codon that will stop
the translation of the sequence
and it will be result in a shorter
protein
and also it could be a change in the
amino acid and that change could be
either
in a specific given position or it could
carry on
so we will have a deformed or a
completely changed
protein as a result okay so let me pause
here i see some questions
can you explain what is frame shift in
reading translated amino acids
well a frame shift means that as you can
see right here
just the reading frame and you can see
that
the result of different changes means
that
the sequence itself of amino acids that
are being produced could be changed
completely
so if you have a specific sequence and
you change
one letter that letter could change the
way that
downstream reading happens or
it could stop it completely that's
called the stop codon
shift frame mutation means that it will
change the subsequent reading
of the nucleotide sequence leading
into different types of amino acids so
does that answer your question mona
all right so now we can think of
how can such a change happen
so one of the questions that we can ask
is
if we align all of these sequences
to each other and we observe some
differences for example here you can see
g and here you see t
if i observe such a change or if i
observe such a change in terms of the
amino acid sequence
it means that the protein that is being
produced from the sequence
is different this causes
some potential change in phenotype
that phenotype could be defined in we're
talking about viruses
in its ability to replicate in different
organs and its ability to
enter cells from different hosts
in its ability to be highly
transmissible
so transmit more effectively between
different individuals in a population so
it's a change in phenotype
so oftentimes the question that we can
ask when we do this
multiple sequence alignment is what is
the relationship
between the observed species and their
ancestors
and the way that we can visualize the
relationship
is called a phylogenetic tree so we can
look at
the evolution the process of change over
time
evolution and we can ask the question of
how are they
interrelated and that phylogenetic
relationship really means that
we assume that they have a common
ancestor
and that ancestor then divided up into
multiple
branches and claims eventually resulting
in the species that we observe so we can
reconstruct that phylogenetic tree by
using
multiple sequence alignment what type of
information can that give us
here you can see an analysis of multiple
samples of ebola viruses
so we have a number of sequences from
ebola viruses from
gabon liberia great britain and we can
ask the question
how do they excuse me how do they relate
to each other
so if that relationship is closer
so for example these are closer to each
other than these
and what is their relationship in time
so looking at the
x-axis we can consider evolutionary time
the process of getting such information
from
sequencing data is alignment
conversion to amino acids and then
what's called a phylogenetic tree
reconstruction using multiple sequence
alignment
based on multiple types of models and
we'll talk about that
in greater detail sometimes we're not
interested in the relationship itself
but we are interested in
a particular change a polar morphism in
the case of
a population or a variant in the case of
a specific genome
and that mutation or a change can
characterize a particular group of
samples or a
individual sample now importantly this
type of an analysis
is based on alignment of reads
to the reference genome so we can have
this is an example of a single sample
the single sample is aligned to the
reference genome
and if it is aligned to the reference
genome we can very confidently
identify some changes because they are
present in multiple reads
if they are present in all of the reads
we will have
high confidence for example here
you can see a change in this position
we have one two three four five changes
we don't have any other data that will
indicate
otherwise well i wouldn't say that this
is a new virus this is some kind of
variant
that emerges because most of the
information is the same
right so if we have um a lot of
similarity
that means that it is the same virus
it's just
developing new adaptations if it
if we see a lot of these and i'll give
you several examples here in just a
second
we can say that maybe it's a new virus
completely so
we'll we'll talk about that in just a
second
okay yes so important terminology here
haplotypes
when we say a new virus we need to
define
if we're looking at different levels of
taxonomy species family phylum etc so we
can talk about that as well
we'll talk about all of these concepts
but right now what i wanted to mention
is just
where the data is coming from and what
type of information are we getting
out of this data so in this particular
example
we are seeing a change a substitution
based on alignment to a reference and
what i wanted to point your attention to
is that
some of these variants have more
confidence than
others for example in this case we have
two sources of data one read and another
read
they do not match to each other and they
do not match to the reference genome
if they don't match that means that we
have
low confidence it could be a result of a
technical error
so most of the time this type of change
is not going to be reported
this type of change will be reported as
a variant
and then sometimes we also can have
multiple regions or multiple letters
inserted or deleted if we have such
indication
these are called indels so different
types of analyses
one of the primary ways to characterize
such data is what's called variant
calling and when we say variant calling
it's to distinguish
between variants like this and all the
other types of variants that we have
low quality of information about and we
can think about
how to compare samples or groups of
samples
to understand whether such a variant is
present in
all of the samples from a population or
just a few
so a lot of questions that could be
asked here let's take a look
at a specific example
so here you can see a
collection of reads so each one of these
lines
is a read mapped onto
a reference genome okay so
what is this reference genome this
referent genome is called
beta coronavirus wuhan
wuhan institute of virology04 2019
ii okay so this is the code name
this is where it came from it's a beta
coronavirus sequenced
in wuhan you have all these reeds
and these reeds are aligned to some
reference now that does not mean that
these reeds came specifically from this
virus you just take a sample
and you're saying okay let me align it
to this specific
type of a reference
you will also have a consensus a
consensus
talks about the majority of the
nucleotides
from the aligned reeds and they could be
very different
from the reference that we are using for
alignment we're just using this
alignment to kind of give it a framework
to follow
as a result we can get multiple types
of genomes assembled genomes and these
assembled genomes
could have specific variations that help
us
characterize those haplotypes
or completely new viruses right so in
the case of
this coronavirus we can talk about these
are samples from bats
these are samples from humans these are
samples from china these are samples
from usa
and this is how they are related to each
other by these specific mutations
by these insertions and deletions or by
these
sections that are completely different
right so then we can start asking
different questions
about how they are related to each other
and what could that mean functionally
so to kind of give you an insight into
all of this practically
we have this multi-omics platform that
we will use
in this program so in the program
we will not only speak about these
examples we'll actually do these
examples together
so when we talk about the specific
samples
or the specific sequences and how they
relate together
we will do some analysis so before i get
to your questions here in just a couple
of minutes
let me give you an overview of the types
of
bioinformatic analysis pipelines so here
what you can see is an example of a
pipeline
how these analysis pipelines could be
done on the t bioinfo platform
to identify phylogenetic tree
reconstruct the phylogenetic tree
to measure gene expression variation
between groups of samples to align
genomes to a reference to
call variants structural alignment
which will give us an insight into what
does this alignment mean
and variant calls so detect variants
that are specific
to a group of samples that are different
between each other
so in this program we will talk about
in different sessions about sequence
variation
evolutionary relationships functional
inference from such
difference and the response from the
host and that gives us a good
overview of host pathogen interaction
but we will go into other examples as
well so let's talk about
how we can do alignment multiple
sequence alignment
so let's go to the platform please
follow with me to server dot
t dash bio dot info and
i hope that this will also give you some
answers to some of these questions
okay so this is the link
please let me know once you are here
okay for those of you that do not have
an account yet
you can easily click on this access
button
and request a demo account for those of
you that do have access you should have
received an email this morning
or last week if you register depending
on when you register
to get access to this platform we will
use this platform extensively
throughout this course and we will talk
about
how you can analyze also data that you
find on your
own to process and to analyze this data
all right if you arrived here and you
are
logged in please please put in one
in the chat box so we know how many of
you are already here
let me just give it a couple more
minutes so that all of you are here
all right excellent thank you very much
so again what we will do
is alignment of sequences just to
understand
what will that look like so here you can
see
phylogenetic tree and we will also
use this section and we'll do this here
today just so that i can talk about some
of these other ways to
study data from here so please go with
me under virus
quasi species even though the same
methods are available in phylogenetic
tree we'll look at virus quasi species
and we'll go to this first demo virus
multiple sequence alignment and
phylogenetic
analysis
so here you can see a combination of
multiple types of
use cases for different types of data
for example
you can start here and analyze data
using multiple sequence alignment so
multiple sequence alignment is done
on faster files you have to have
assembled sequences you already know
what the full sequence is
you want to align them to each other so
multiple sequence alignment
essentially aligns the different
sequences that you have
and here you can see some examples of
different types of beta corona viruses
aligned to the wuhan reference
sequence and then convert them to amino
acids that have
different physical chemical properties
that we will talk about
you can also analyze how the different
types of codons you can see that
each change could be a result of changes
in different positions in the codon so
we can look at the different
preferences over which positions we are
incorporating
and then we want to reconstruct a
phylogenetic tree so we'll look at
phylogenetic trees coming from multiple
methods these multiple methods will
produce small variations or significant
variations
in how the relationship is organized and
how
the time the evolutionary time is
reconstructed so we can click on the
tree space
to study the variation between different
results
and then let's click on end
and you will see here download pipeline
output files
okay so how many of you were able to
create this pipeline
if you were able to create the pipeline
please put number two
in the chat box
all right thank you
anita
all right so for amy again i'm showing
here on the screen you go from start
multiple sequence alignment multiple
sequence alignment a a
select codon position msa
and then all phylogeny methods tree
space and
end all right so you can review the
video
afterwards and try to replicate these
steps the important part of this
is that you should get some of these
demo
example results so here you can see
multiple pdfs these pdfs are going to be
of the phylogenetic tree and this
phylogenetic tree is produced by
four different methods four different
models or three models for beast
and one model for ape you can also see
a final kind of
tree and you can also see the actual
output table which aligns all of the
data
but does not tell us how it's related
just on alignment
importantly we can visually interrogate
such data so this specific output right
here
you can open it in excel but it's a
fairly large
data file and we'll talk about how to
deal with these data files
but i want to briefly visually
illustrate
what this data contains in terms of
information
so please go to me go with me to this
link
this is the direct output from what we
just saw
it's a sequence navigator that we've
developed to visualize such data
and will give us a sense for how these
different types of
uh sequences are related to each other
so the data set i'm going to be using
is this one comparison of the birth
death coronavirus
so you don't even have to follow along
necessarily right now
just as long as you know that that
output file could be visualized in such
a way
what we see here is how
thousands of nucleotides so this whole
reference sequence is about 30 000
nucleotides long for the beta
coronavirus or for the sars coronavirus
about 30 000 nucleotides altogether
when we align the reference when we
align all of these samples to the
reference
all these are faster files to the
reference
we can observe how many positions are
changing
from the reference in a bin so here we
can
change between bin sizes for example 250
or 500 nucleotides
and we can start seeing that some of
these are significantly different
from the reference so the more red they
are the
less gray they are the more different
they are from the reference
and we can identify whole sections on
the genome
that are significantly different in a
given
protein producing gene so here you can
see
a gene that is not protein coding
and here's the gene the blue one that is
protein coding
this gene happens to be the surface
glycoprotein or the spike
protein the spike protein and we'll talk
a lot more about the spike protein
is responsible for cell binding to the
cell receptors and
entry of the virus into the host and we
can see that there's
a lot of variation in this gene
between the different groups of samples
now these groups of samples are
organized by
the type of coronavirus that these
samples represent beta coronavirus
covid19 sars and myrrh so obviously
stars cove two and we can see that which
according to what you see in this
visualization
which group is the most similar to the
novel coronavirus that causes cocaine
so which other group mers sars
or beta coronavirus is the closest
to this virus that causes copenhagen
okay so a beer is saying mers
any other guesses
so again the question is which group of
samples
is the closest to this group of samples
right here for covert 19
based on sequence similarity okay so amy
is saying sars anita is saying
sars athanasios is saying beta corona
virus
is so again gray
means it's identical so you can see this
is zero changes
from the reference genome so here we see
all of these are gray
probably leads us to think that the
reference that we're using here
is a beta coronavirus or the source code
2 genome
now we see here this group sars
has the least differences right these
are zero differences so whole sections
are actually identical to here
and some of these contain a smaller
number so smaller than the tens
if we go over to the mers this has
hundreds
of changes this has hundreds
of changes so it's obvious if you look
at this image
that sars is the closest to code 19
that's why
source code ii is closely related to
source code one
which is the stars section right here we
can visualize
the way that they are interrelated by
building a phylogenetic tree so this
phylogenetic tree you can see it's
annotated
beta corona viruses mers covet
and sars and you can see that this clade
right so this and this
represents a common branch from the main
phylogenetic tree
for covet 19 and sars so sars1
and sars2 are the closest to each other
based on a comparison between these
different types of viruses
does anyone have any questions about
this
all right if you have any questions
please post your questions in the chat
box and we'll address them in just a
second the second type of analysis that
we'll briefly describe
is variant calling different types of
data remember that this is
fast queue files not fast ah files
right and here the objective is to
identify specific positions that are
very different
from the reference genome and these
could be a result of selective pressure
variants and mutations that are
associated with
a phenotype so let's take a look at an
example
here we have the ebola virus so we can
ask
two different questions from this data
one
question is let's visualize this data
okay so if we visualize the data
we are expecting to see something that
looks like this
and here we will find specific mutations
specific positions in multiple samples
that all agree that there's a change
from the reference genome
so somebody previously had a question
about reference
or sorry coverage right here in the gray
you can see the coverage
right here on the bottom you can see the
actual reads
so if we just visualize our data we can
look at the reads but we can also ask
well altogether how many reads are
aligned to each position
which gives us a lot of different
confidence measures
for how we can be confident in a
particular change
so if we do variant calling we can
identify specific
proteins that have very defined
mutations in groups of samples
these groups of mutations can help us
characterize changes in the protein
structure
and function and if we find those
changes
they could be critical for design and
development of vaccines
because we know that vaccines are only
as good
as the type of a virus structure that
they represent
so that's an important thing to remember
and we'll talk about that
in a lot more detail in the future
now we some the question here doesn't
matter which
tree building method is used here
obviously that does matter
let's take a look at what these trees
actually
tell us so here's an example with ebola
virus again
and let's go to a website called next
strain i'm sure that
most of you have probably already heard
about it
so next strain is a place where you can
look at
different types of relationships based
on data
and and some information about
what this data represents in terms of
where it was collected etc
so you can see that there's a repository
here on source code too
other types of viruses tuberculosis uh
ebola vaccine or so sorry ebola
viruses etc so here you can see a number
of different resources
and we can go to this uh
link for ebola virus okay and this is
a community project from a variety of
um a variety of
groups that have collected samples from
different locations in the 2013-2016
west african ebola epidemic so this tree
that you see represents the
diversification of the viral
as the virus spread between these
different locations
okay so if you just play this animation
it shows you
how samples from different locations
and the associated number of deaths or
infection
from these different types of in
different locations
has caused a change in the viral
sequence now if you scroll down here
okay let's do reset you can see
in which proteins on the reference
genome
did these mutations accumulate so let me
ask you a question out of all the
proteins that you see on this reference
genome
which protein do you think
has the highest diversity measurement
this is the y-axis the diversity
measurement
so which protein has a position that is
the highest
in terms of its diversity
okay so muhammad is saying sgp
so this is sgp right here anyone else
all right so uh some of you think sgp
some of you think
l i think l is the correct because you
can
see here if you hover over it says
uh entropy 0.357
okay here you see entropy 0.285
so 0 3 5 7
is more than 0 2 8 5.
so the correct answer is 3 19 and here's
three eight five so three five seven
right so this is the highest one
the l protein yep
it is difficult to see but this just
gives you some insight
into how important it is to
select the correct data and the correct
analysis
for what you are trying to do so again
if you play this
and you pause it
this changes right so where you sample
then how much data you have this is this
window
within this window your results could be
completely different
so some of you mentioned sgp nobody
really mentioned np
but you can see that in this case this
position
is the highest in vp35
and so at this point in time what was
known
is that the difference between these
groups was best characterized
by mutations in this position in this
protein
so you might have thought okay well this
protein is the most important
as you continue playing this and you
pause in a different moment in time
that information will change so here np
is the highest
right so really the data is only
is very critical for the analysis and
for interpretation
that we will do so this is just an
example but i think also
it's important to remember the
significance of the data
the type of data and the type of
analysis so we'll talk a lot more
about the ebola virus these particular
mutations that we are observing
the types of analyses that we can do
with what kind of data
and even discover haplotypes and not
just the specific
mutations but actual haplotypes that are
different
and we'll talk about the significance of
this type of viral diversity studies
that could be
an impact on the phenotype on how fast
the virus spreads
how severe is the disease that it causes
and what are the
results from such studies that have an
impact on antiviral
drug design and vaccine design any
questions
okay so we're already running out of
time so let me briefly introduce you to
two
other mentors for this program
uh dr harpreet kawar and dr mohit
mazumdar
will help you get the most out of this
program so
we will have a number of practical
exercises running these types of
analyses
analyzing the data in r looking at the
relationships between different types of
samples
and we will look at how you can develop
a project of your own so we will
see how these examples that we present
in the course of this program are really
designed to introduce you to
data repositories and analysis methods
for you to develop your own independent
uh methods and thinking about
bioinformatics analysis
so let me pass it on to dr harpreet kahr
she will just briefly introduce her
background
thank you
so hello everyone my name is harpreet
kaur
and i have a phd in bioinformatics
my research is on omix biomarker
discovery
for diagnosis and prognosis of liver
cancer
in my current role i am omics logic
bioinformatics trainer
with pine biotech i am looking forward
to being your mentor during this
bioinformatics
for infectious disease program and help
all
of you to learn about data analysis
machine learning
and visualization in the application to
large datasets
used in the biomedical research
especially in infectious disease i will
be happy to assist
all of the participants in designing an
analysis
of the research project or any kind of
analysis so now i would
like to pass this session back to ilya
so
over to you india okay thank you
harpreet so again
we will have a number of technical
uh technical um sessions where we will
run analysis together
look at the results and we will also
introduce
some of the um some of the
uh examples in r and uh uh
and uh sorry harpreet will be guiding
those sessions
and answering your technical questions
so let me now pass it on to uh
dr mohit mazumdar who will talk a little
bit about
project mentorship
thank you india and hello everyone
my name is mazumdar and i am one of the
global representatives of pi biotech
in my current role i am working with
scientists and researchers and students
to assist with their omics big data
research
and collaborating with universities to
provide support for bioinformatics
training
and education bioinformatics for an
infectious disease
is a special program during this uh
summer during this last summer we had
this
unique opportunity to work with experts
in data science
code 19 research ebola malaria
tuberculosis
and many life-threatening diseases and
where we are
where we were trying to find answers to
critical questions
so during the last program we worked
with our participants
and throughout the program because of
that
that resulted in more than 50
independent bioinformatics
research proposals and projects so the
projects proposals were then peer
reviewed by experts
and later the video presentation was
recorded by our participants
on topics such as different versions of
human reference genome in rna-seq
analysis
gr37 and gs38 and their influence on
in vitro studies of kuvit-19 drug test
on human
organoids then another project was about
genetic predeposition to acquire a
polybasic cleavage site for highly
pathogenic h1n1 hematoglutin virus
so there were several uh research
proposals that we worked through
during that uh last during our last
program
so with this introduction i would like
to pass it on to ms beepsha
to take you further thank you
thank you so much dr mohit for that
overview
and to elia as well
so before i start giving you all an
overview of the different resources
i wanted to talk to you all about what
omix logic programs
are so the goal of our omits logic
programs
is to provide training in bioinformatics
enabling
independent research guided by mentors
and pure
example developing a growing community
with shared passion for data-driven
research and appreciation of citizen
science
enabling students clinicians and faculty
of all backgrounds to develop
novel and independent research using
latest technology
in life and data sciences
in our omics logic programs we will
combine
online sessions self-guided study
materials and practical assignments
for an immersive experience that has
proven to be effective
as you can see here so we will have
sessions like we did
today participants will have access to
courses as well as we will be able to
track
all kinds of participant progress
throughout
this program and
i will shortly demonstrate this for
everyone
together with our collaborators we have
been building a growing online community
of buy information in training
ranging from high school students to
faculty and researchers
in top universities around the world our
team offers big data analysis tools
like the server t by info platform and
the seek nav
that we showed today
in programs designed around various
topics
we discussed bioinformatics approaches
for processing
analysis integration and interpretation
of multi-omics data
from oncology neuroscience agrobiology
and infectious diseases
i encourage you all to sign up for free
on one of our portals and start
learning or teaching bioinformatics it
is one of the best ways we can explore
the world around us
at the molecular level with zero
equipment
or lab costs so now let us look at some
of the resources
that we will get as part of this program
i'm sure most of the participants
already have received an
email from my end regarding the
resources and also they are familiar
with
it so this is what we call our
bioinformatics
organization page for all of our
programs so for the bioinformatics for
infectious disease program
this is your organization page
and here we will have the list of all
the events
mentioned so today we are on 9th
november
and we have covered the topic of next
generation sequencing viral genomes in
host transcriptome
and we have answered questions we still
have
a lot of the questions in chat which we
will be answering
in a few more minutes and the next
session would be on multiple sequence
alignment
and phylogeny if you have not yet signed
up you can still sign up for
this program and you see here
in this page we will be able to see the
progress
and the activity of all the members who
are joining the program
now before i move on i want to show you
what a proof profile looks like so anita
i'm borrowing your profile for an
example
because anita here has a completed
profile
so if you are a participant or whether
you are joining us for the first time
i would request you to complete your
profile so what does a complete profile
looks like it looks like this where you
have a profile image
and you have your full name mentioned so
when you sign up probably
this would just be your username so you
can change it via your profile
and using the edit button that you will
get after you click
on profile and you can also add your
social media links
so the profile is helpful because
as you saw that you know we collaborate
with our program participants
on different projects and then these
projects are also sent for peer review
so
this way members in our community will
be able to
learn more from you you would be able to
collaborate with each other
and even if you're not joining this
program you can still have the
opportunity to go out and explore
and talk and network with people in the
community so that is the reason
we would want you to have a complete
profile
and also having a complete name will
also be marked on your course
certificates
which you get after completing the
courses that are there on the platform
and now moving on from the organization
page
we will also be having access to the
forums
so as you see here is a topic posted on
the forum
called session recording so this session
will again be posted there
so we will have various topics on
different
ideas where participants can communicate
with us
even beyond these live sessions
and then you have access to asynchronous
courses
so some of you may already have taken
the introduction to bioinformatics
course
and if you have not yet taken this
course please go ahead and take the
first
basic course which is free for everyone
as is introduction to genomics so you
will be able to find them as well under
here
introduction to bioinformatics so all
participants will have
access to these different courses as
well as
projects so you see here is one project
on ebola
and as elia mentioned we will be
discussing these
in depth in the upcoming sessions and
for
all participants we will be able to see
everybody's progress right here on the
tab so today
as everyone is joining we do not have a
lot of data from everyone because we are
just starting the session today
but as we move forward we will be seeing
that there will be
several different graphs of these colors
where we will be able to track your
progress across all of our platforms
the pink uh is suggestive of
the codomix logic platform the
server platform is denoted by the gray
and yellow is for the courses and
activities that you do right here
and now moving on the other things that
the participants will have access to is
the
server t by info platform now i know
that a lot of people have in
uh requested the demo access to the
platform so the demo
access to the server t by info platform
will only give you
access to demo pipelines you won't be
able to upload your data or do any of
the hands-on
analysis but all participants should
have
access educational access to the
platform and this
platform is also available for research
access
and if you need more information on that
please email us at marketinginfine.bio
i'm just putting my email down in the
chat again
and harshit i'll just get back to your
question in one more minute
the other platform which elia also
mentioned a while ago
which was uh practicing in r
and python so we have courses on the
codemix logic platform
where participants will be able to
utilize this platform for a
browser-based experience
i'm sorry about this browser-based
experience
of utilizing r and python
for training and learning from these
data sets that we discussed today and
also from
other data sets and also the seek nav
which we had seen today so these are
some of the resources that are there
as part of the bioinformatics for
infectious disease program
and we'll of course talk about the other
resources like we mentioned
some of the public domain repositories
which we will be mentioning throughout
this program
and utilize those data sets for our own
projects
and see how we can learn about viral
diseases
and to answer harshita's question
the training certificate okay so
harshita for the training certificate
we have a parameter which we call
getting 10 000 points so you do not
necessarily have to complete
all of the courses listed there we hope
you do
and once you have over 10 000 points
i'll show anita's
so anita has been in a few programs and
she has over
24 000 points so she has received
uh certificates of excellence in the
past so
if you have over 10 000 points you
receive a certificate of excellence
if you have anything below 10 points we
give out a certificate of completion
we hope that you
uh go through the different resources
that are available and the different
courses which we make completely
available to you
for the program so i have a question
from
mona right here the question is
how to maintain our membership so we
will be able to use these programs
beyond
the 2nd of december to answer this
question
very quickly there are several
membership options
that you can take and i think that
once we go to the end of the program we
can
send you the different links that we
have to the membership
options so that you can keep on your
access to the different resources
for the program or the resources to
your access to the server platform
so each time you do uh complete a course
so the question is how much points do
each course carry so the points that
each course carry is 500 points
so once you complete a course you get
500 points and
getting to 10 000 is not at all
difficult
because you will not only be doing
courses you will be running pipelines
that gives you
50 points again each of the pipelines
that you run
as well as the codements logic platform
will also carry points
so it should not be very difficult the
only thing that you would have to do
is keep on maintaining this and doing
the courses at your own free time you
don't have to do it
along with us but you can do it at your
own free time during this
one month program and utilize these
different resources
now i would want to pass this on to elia
elia back to you
thank you very much biebsta uh so as you
saw we presented here
what we can learn about
viral and bacterial pathogens by
analyzing their genomes
we talked a little bit about
next-generation sequencing which is key
to this kind of ability to analyze and
ask questions of the data
and we talked a little bit about some
additional resources that if you see
gaps in your knowledge
for example if you are not familiar with
some of the terminology that we use
today you don't understand the reads you
don't
understand coverage you don't understand
how this data is prepared
we ask you to use some of the
synchronous resources to
catch up and be ready for this program
some of the data sets that we will
analyze are fairly big
so you will see data sets that are
gigabytes in size
and hundreds of megabytes in size to
analyze
and process all of this data on your own
computer can be
prohibitive just because of the size of
memory and cpu
and your pipelines will just take
forever so to make this program go
faster we've prepared this
online resource called the tbi for
platform we'll also
introduce you very quickly to advanced
methods of analysis you don't have to
wait
and build the pipeline the pipelines are
already pre-built
the results are already informative as
you will get them
and then finally this community that we
have allows you to interact
with mentors peers work together on
projects
ask questions make sure that you start
getting into the more interesting and
advanced
questions much faster so what we'll do
in the next several sessions is go over
sequence analysis alignment phylogenetic
trees
analysis of genomic and transcriptomic
data and you'll start seeing
how some of these publications that talk
about viral
phylogenetic relationships uh resistance
to
antibiotic drugs and also
relationship with the immune response
and disease progression could be
answered
using data sets that are already
available on
ncbi and other publicly available
resources
for those of you that have already
joined the program i have
an assignment so for those of you
that are just joining and you're still
not familiar with
many of the terms that we're using we
ask you to complete introduction to
bioinformatics actually this is also for
those that are joining for the first
time
and you just want to try one of these
courses this is a course that is free
you can complete it in probably under
one hour
and what it has is an overview of
different types of
important terms and concepts and how
bioinformatics is used across
a wide range of applications
importantly it also has a survey
that helps us learn about you and
propose some meaningful
coursework or programs that are upcoming
so really
a way to personally address some of the
interests that you might have
this type of material has been reviewed
by
faculty undergraduate and graduate
students and all of them agree
that this information even though it
might seem a little bit introductory is
useful
even if you are a professor or a
researcher
and especially if you're a student so
it's an introductory course
but can provide an interesting level of
detail
we also ask you if you're already done
with introduction to bioinformatics
to complete a course on metagenomics
this will give you some
insights into what types of data
could be extracted from sequencing data
we have a course called introduction to
metagenomics which again is free
or metagenomics one if you're a part of
the program and for a
project we ask you to look at spot of
therapy peridot which is
a project that allows you to analyze
uh sequencing data and detect a novel
pathogen to characterize it and
understand
why it might be important for a
biologic's production
uh pipeline for biotechnology companies
so again your assignment is to look at
spot uptera fujiperda
complete introduction to bioinformatics
introduction to metagenomics or
metagenomics one
and also we have a blog post that talks
about virology resources for those of
you that are interested
in virology and how to analyze
virology data please take a look at this
blog
post that will allow you to
explore some of the databases and some
of the
tools that are available in these
different repositories so this is the
link
to to here
okay um let me answer some of the
questions that i've seen
here um okay so the question could you
reference tbi info platform is used in
publications yes
we have a whole link to a list of
publications for different
algorithms many of the algorithms used
on the platform that our public domain
have been used extensively on a variety
of different
projects so we have a list of those
publications we'll be happy to send you
a detailed view
of uh what it does um
so please email us marketing
at pinebio and we'll get back to you
with any additional questions um i
wanted to
summarize by sharing
a profile of someone who is successfully
completed the project and some of the
feedback that we
got from that person because i think
many of you might be wondering
what is the difference between this
program
and some of the other online programs
that you might get in data science and
bioinformatics
maybe in molecular biology or virology
so i think that what we've seen
is that many of the activities combined
together
really develop in an experience that is
not similar to many of these programs
we don't take just general concepts and
go through
the methodology we guide you on how to
ask
questions about data and answer them
using analytical tools
the objective of the program and for
those of you that really want to succeed
in the program is really to develop an
independent project
so there are several reasons why you
might choose to
be a participant in the program and
benefit from all of these resources
together
the analytical platform the coding
platform
the educational asynchronous courses and
the interactive sessions that we will
have
and so beeps has just posted a link to
this blog you can
go through the blog and just kind of see
some of the
reasons why um the people that really
benefit from the program have joined and
how it's different from some of the
other online resources
also we are whether you're a part of
this program or not a part of this
program we welcome you to join our
groups
on linkedin and facebook we post their
regularly
resources free data sets uh example
projects as well as opportunities for
career development
uh on these groups so if you are a
budding bioinformatician or you're an
expert in the field
we want to be connected in the long term
so please join
our groups on social media that will
help us stay in touch
and i do want to mention uh that this
program is going to continue
um for the next um several sessions
we will have um a special recording of
this session made available and we'll be
happy to share with you if you've
already registered with an email
and i'm happy to answer any final
questions before we finish this session
okay well if there's no questions right
now i was
excited to get started with this program
and hope to see
all of you join us again next time thank
you for
registering and we are looking forward
to working with you on developing your
own independent bioinformatics projects
in the next few weeks we'll have this
recording shared with you by email
anyone that wanted the materials you can
review that in your own time
and if you have any additional questions
please feel free to reach out to us
again marketing at pinepipe dot bio
thank you again
and we will see you again next time